hello scp foundation personnel welcome
to cognito hazards and you episode
rejected this video series is intended
to teach you about the protocol
surrounding the various cognitohazardous
anomalies currently within foundation
containment when you know better you do
better and both you and the secrets of
our great organization can stay safe and
as anyone familiar with a good
cognitohazard can tell you knowing
really can make a difference today's
episode is about the unique and
dangerous scp-2316
before we begin repeat after me and be
sure to speak clearly into the
microphone in front of you i do not
recognize the bodies in the water a
little louder please thank you in order
to be educated about the following scp
you must pass a vocal examination with a
cognitive resistance value of no less
than 14.5
through this video presentation you will
need to repeat the phrase to ensure your
score does not drop below the approved
threshold in the event that you fail the
test stay calm and remain where you are
until medical staff can retrieve you
remember safety is a top priority when
observing cognito hazards the safe way
is the only way you're a cog in a very
important machine and we wouldn't want
to have to terminate you now would we
one more time please i do not recognize
the bodies in the water very good
remember that you do not recognize them
no matter what you might think you see
your thoughts can be very unreliable
when you're around
scp-236
according to our files on the matter
scp-2316 refers to an anomalous
phenomenon identified in a small town
lake it appears as a collection of human
bodies floating in a group on the
surface of the water the exact number of
corpses is unknown but it has been
estimated to be anywhere between 45 and
200 though the bodies belong to
individuals many researchers theorize
that the bodies in the water which you
do not recognize and you have never
recognized share a collective
consciousness they function it would
seem with a hive mind of sorts the
bodies do not act on their own but as
one now where does the
hazard come into play it would seem that
anyone who looks at the bodies in the
water or learns too much about
scp-2316 as a whole begins to believe
the corpses floating in the lake are
people they recognize perhaps they
remember their faces from childhood or
high school whatever the case may be
they become convinced that the bodies in
the water are familiar and that they
must approach them no matter how
familiar they might seem however you do
not recognize the bodies in the water if
a person attempts to enter the lake
reaching out to whatever instances of
scp-2316 they think they recognize more
bodies will begin to appear the more
bodies appear the more familiar faces
seem to manifest and the deeper the
person will venture into the lake
eventually the person is lost within the
sea of bodies likely drowning beneath
the surface or simply becoming one with
a hive mind until they too are one of
the corpses there none of the
individuals who wandered into the lake
in search of an old friend or classmate
have ever been recovered there have been
no attempts to search the lake for their
bodies as it is unknown what effect
scp-2316 would have on the team assigned
to such a task though we can guess that
the outcome would likely be extremely
negative for all involved those who do
venture into the lake simply disappear
never to be seen again if you look too
long at the bodies in the lake perhaps
their faces would surface alongside the
rest but it's best not to think about
that after all we do not recognize the
bodies in the water foundation personnel
are not allowed to approach scp-2316
under any circumstances the lake is only
permitted to be observed via dummy
probes outfitted with video and audio
recording equipment no one is permitted
to observe any footage or audio files
collected unless they pass through a
screening for resilience to cognito
hazardous anomalies the lake that holds
scp-2316 has been fenced off and is
patrolled by guards with no prior
knowledge of or exposure to scp-2316
anyone who attempts to approach the lake
and break through the boundaries of its
quarantine will be seized and taken to
site-33 for examination anyone who comes
within 50 meters of the lake is
considered lost and presumed dead repeat
after me slowly and clearly into the
microphone i do not recognize the bodies
in the water good i almost believe you
let's continue only one foundation
officer that entered the lake containing
scp-2316 was ever stopped before they
could be lost their name has been
stricken from any official records and
you do not need to know it their
identity does not matter what matters is
the interview they gave following the
incident conducted by dr harrison in his
office dr harrison asked the anonymous
officer if they felt compelled to enter
the water by an invisible force as if
pulled in they rejected this concept
entirely insisting that they entered the
water of their own free will they wanted
to see the bodies who appeared to them
as their friends they wanted to hear
what the bodies were saying upon
entering the water they saw the faces of
their friends other faces were
unfamiliar but became more familiar the
longer the officer stared at their
features these were faces they had known
their entire life but something about
them was just a little bit wrong it was
like the face of someone in a dream
where you can tell they are someone you
know and you can even identify who it is
supposed to be but something about them
does not quite look right your mind
could not perfectly put their face
together from memory even though the
feeling of familiarity remains the faces
in the water peering up through the
darkness below were like those
dream-addled memories the faces in the
water did not open their mouths but
somehow they spoke to the officer just
the same they spoke of who they were and
asked for help they asked to be seen to
be touched they spoke of the foundation
accusing us of covering up their deaths
and keeping the world from remembering
what happened to them at this point in
the interview the subject became
agitated yelling at dr harrison and
refusing to be quiet guards intervened
holding the subject still as they fought
yelling at dr harrison repeating over
and over that they could hear the body
speaking to them every single one the
interview ended when the guards removed
the subject from the room taking them to
the amnestics department to have all
memory of the bodies in the water erase
from their mind then they were forgotten
once more i do not recognize the bodies
in the water did you repeat it good
we do not recognize the bodies in the
water we can't the motivations of
scp-2316
if it has any at all are largely unclear
there are those on the research staff
that theorize the hive mind or
collective consciousness of the bodies
is not malevolent in nature it is they
believe simply trying to make sure that
a tragedy that occurred in that lake is
remembered perhaps many lives were lost
to an anomalous force in that lake and
the impact of that massive tragedy left
behind an impression on the location
this impression manifests in the form of
bodies spontaneously appearing in an
impossibly well preserved condition the
cognitohazard of scp-2316
is not intended to kill anyone or take
them but rather to force strangers to
remember the people who lost their lives
to the lake this sense of familiarity
whether it is false or not ensures that
the dead will not be forgotten or left
alone after all no one deserves to be
left alone though there have been lives
lost to the cognito hazard according to
the foundation it is understandable why
the bodies would want to be recognized
to have someone somewhere know who they
were to have someone remember their
names jeremiah feynman arthur scott
denise clarke
where was i oh yes repeat after me once
again i do not recognize the bodies in
the water i do not recognize them i do
not
but that's a lie isn't it i do recognize
them how could i not i know them they're
my friends do you recognize them look at
their faces don't fight the memories
look into their eyes the class of 1975.
they were supposed to graduate that fall
they were just kids group of innocent
kids lost to the dark and deep what
happened to them i can't
quite remember but i know that it
mattered enough for the foundation to
keep the secret and i know that somehow
i survive but i shouldn't have i should
be there with them i should be there
there isn't much time i can hear the
guards coming to retrieve me their
footsteps thundering down the hall i
failed the test and the alarm has gone
off they think i'm lost but i'm not i've
never been less lost in my entire life
i've finally woken up to the truth i
remember i have to go i have to return
to the lake fall of 1975 they went for a
swim my friends they're calling to me i
can hear them so clearly even from so
far away their cries for help ringing in
my ears their voices curling around me
pulling me to the edge of the water the
guards will come for you too they'll
know you've seen this they'll call you
compromise they'll say i succumb to the
effects of the cognitohazard they'll say
you did too you'll fail their little
tests and they'll say that makes you
weak and broken but you cannot listen
they're lying it's not a hazard it's a
scream for help they're screaming and
the foundation keeps covering it up they
won't let us find them and they won't
tell us
why i have to go back so we can be
together again there are signs posted
all around the lake danger drowning
hazard those are a trick it's to keep me
out
to keep the truth from me the barbed
wire fences around it it's just another
trick i'll climb over it rung after rung
i don't care if the barbs tear my
clothes or pierce my skin it's worth it
for the truth for the memory and once
i've climbed to the top i'll be able to
see there through the fog i can see
their faces their lips parted in a
constant cry their eyes wide looking for
me
my friends
my family
every face unlocking a memory long
buried i know them all
and i must go further i can't turn back
now i have to wade into the water let
its chill soak into my clothes down to
my bones one step and another deeper and
deeper the water lapping at my ankles my
knees my thighs the deeper i go the more
sure i will be that this is where i
belong the water will engulf my chest my
neck until my feet no longer touch the
ground i will be lost in it water
flooding into my mouth pouring into
every opening i will let my body sink
down down down to the bottom where
they've been all this time nestled in
the dirt and the dust they've been so
patient but it's finally time they're
ready to be remembered to be seen to be
found they're waiting for me and they're
waiting for you too can you hear them
i'm going now you have to find me you
have to follow me don't let the guards
stop you don't let them wipe it all away
from your mind fight break free and find
the lake hop the fence make your way
into the water you can't leave me there
to fade away floating in the cold with
the rest can you hear us
we're waiting
now go check out
scp-2317 the devourer of worlds and
scp-4812 wrath for more mind-bending and
mysterious scps